let's play a while more people
challenging me
I'll play a random sub playing Hegel's
devastation oh is this heigl bagel this
might be heigl bagel from earlier what
to play let's play play something
reasonable been playing too many f5
moves from the stream I could physically
hover the board of my screen yeah I
could have put a blanket over my monitor
but I feel like that would be abusing
the blanket but maybe not so in this
position I have a threat my threat was
94 huh it's interesting though you know
I understand that I'll get revenge
eventually also my blindfold I think my
blindfold is in the freezer forgot to
take it out always play a 6 plot twist
opponents spent the past hour preparing
against f5 yeah I maybe I didn't explain
that my blindfold is like um it's a
sleeping mask but it's good for like
kind of but I'm managing I'm I'm trying
to hold my ground against the chat
I think tog II was that wasn't my only
losses stream I lost several games at
the beginning of the stream but it was
my most recent loss but ya know the
blindfold is like also an ice pack and
it's it's very soothing for like head
pain and playing so much chess just so
many headaches right oh griller thinking
real jack or for gifting gifting a sub
from three hours ago that's nice
well not b6 I want to play b5 actually I
think I wanted to put the pawn back on
b7 but that's okay
order the odds my opponent gets forts
like Queens eggs are 394 I feel like
very high percentage White's gonna get
Forks on the next move but we'll see
maybe my opponent heard that and now is
being extra careful ooh
queenie for so I could take the pawn on
uncie too
hmm I'm looking at 5:05 is close to
working takes ticks but then takes I
don't have 92 because the Knights
defends I always have g5
Angie five I could play this move I
think this is a the more the most fork
inducing move well I'm trying to remove
the Knights if I can remove the knight
then I can juice some Forks maybe I
don't think though the blindfold
improves dark circles when you said dark
circles I thought you were talking about
like these types of circles on squares
omid welcome back what it do if you're
referring to my bishop the bishop is
doing attack against the Knights with
the eventual hopes of a forking
hey nice comment from us and see you're
awesome I thoroughly enjoy your streams
and personality very nice thanks so much
okay the fork is about to come I think I
could start with f5 oh there's a funny
line what I'm gonna take first first of
all it takes I this work I think it
works okay so I'm expecting takes if we
don't get this funny line I'll show it
after the game I'm hoping to get it
during the game f5 the idea is to chase
the Queen away and it looks like I'm
blundering it actually really looks like
I'm wandering but it's all part of the
plan
[Music]
or is it maybe I'm bluffing I guess
we'll see yeah so this is what I was
hoping for because now I've Ricky eight
and both nights are hanging but neither
night is take about cuz the other night
will deliver a fork and meanwhile the
Queen's traps
b6 played a very useful role it was a
mouse slip earlier but it plays a useful
role in controlling the two squares that
should be accessible for the Queen
Mike controls the square my queen
controls the square might defends upon
these Knights are guarded the rook
controls the file pawn controls this
square and I'm not getting mated because
the knight obstructs a live Bishop
battery and my queen helps control these
squares so it's a queen trap that's so
nice oh twitch the twitch chat is saying
hi to YouTube so the YouTube people
watching in the future should say hi to
the twitch chats it's only polite Bishop
takes d4 okay let's take I could also
throw in 92 let's take a break can you
draw some more arrows and highlight more
squares soon just be patient
ah okay I was singing Queen g5 of that
kind of blunder as a queen I could be
adventurous let's be adventurous yeah so
I'm attacking the king he has to move
there and John Davis wants more
highlights I mean this is my plan to
play g4 my knight controls these squares
that the dish it can move to oh but the
knight defends of Bishop I forgot about
that arrow oh dear my worse I think I'm
worse here
i trapped the queen earlier but now i've
been losing a night because a bishop
also eyes inking my night chops a bishop
kind of but the bishop traps and nights
that's unfortunate I got too excited now
I'm I'm suffering any tricks with the
Knights Desperados I have this move now
to move I want to play even though g5 is
usually a move I want to play okay I
mean I have to fight back is a now White
has more than enough material for the
Queen may play g4
yeah I got a pawn storm to use my pawns
cuz I'm out of minor pieces he'll defend
the pawn I want to play c5 next I mean
this alignments scary that have to live
with it
launching have to look on the bright
side of things
wait am I am I about to trap lights
night giving why the taste of his own
medicine it almost works but it kind of
doesn't work okay let's start with this
queen bee seventeen cuddling the queen
aligning with the king ideas to play
eventually h3 inmate on g2 that's about
to be very bizarre problem is I'm down
upon which is very unfortunate and
that's a very good move hmm this is very
unfortunate
my question is how do I survive this
things are about to simplified radical
II regrets six doesn't work I could take
the night hmm
okay I'll do this first
I have interesting idea actually to play
King f7 here oh no waking up sevens good
okay I'll go for this line okay at least
I won the night there is a point where
white could have play tonight be it but
should be okay what is this
25
mm-hmm
I'm losing ponds that's unfortunate
clicking g5 became g5 not so bad Nikki
wants to f4 it's very scary
let's do it okay let's push an H upon
[Music]
wait a minute the rooks almost trapped
let's play this I feel like trapping is
a very big theme in the scheme I'm so
close to trapping the rook oh wow it
almost kind of works let's play this I
have this move all that rook defends
rook defends a rook now I have a really
nice trap there too it's unfortunate
how dear
what's going on here each three there
they're there to try this g3 chops my
king
this is getting very complex it may not
seem like it but I'm I'm having some
meeting attack or maybe it does seem
like it Brooksie six Wow play c4
explosive it's funny after it takes
takes the rook and pawn or pins to mate
and pawn can't be taken oh that's a move
okay let's play this move
hmm
it's tricky I'm losing more pawns
I needed that H pawn
oh wow not taking yet
so close yet so far
hmm and this move
it's complicated it's complicated
and white skiing also looks some trouble
of four second increments
I think white should have taken on each
three bouts a flag ooh
[Music]
play this move and then this move still
threatening meet no more checks my
witness I think I'm winning there's no
defense for a white Wow
there's just no defense does King f1
soul mates well the game that's
stressful good fights haggles
devastation there's a line so when I
played b5 I thought my opponent was
gonna fall into it
rookie six was very good kind of in
between move I was envisioning you work
f4 and then Kim g5 and the rook is
trapped my pawns are so so effective and
the Queen defends are basically prevents
white from playing g3 and there's no
rookie for the rook has just dead but
yeah I'm sure there were a lot of
blunders in that game that the computer
graph already like showing some
earthquakes anyway for you two people
watching in the future I hope you
enjoyed that hope you enjoy the
thumbnail that thumbnail where the
physician was quite some it was quite
thumbnail worthy